have you ever wanted to be a hacker I
forgot about how you would gain access
to a system you weren't supposed to well
in this video you're gonna see how you
can make add a cat to that more secure
by donning your own attacker hat and
trying to break it when it comes to
security
you don't just flip a switch and
suddenly your app is secure instead of
thinking of it as yes or no it's better
think of it as a spectrum even with an
app as simple as add a cat to that we've
got a lot of work to keep our
application from becoming one of those
security horror stories you read about
there's a few ways we can make some
progress the first step is putting on
our attacker hat and doing an exercise
called threat modeling in threat
modeling you take advantage of the fact
that you are the best person to attack
your software you have the most in-depth
knowledge of it then you use those
possible attack methods to make your
application more secure remember an
attacker is probably not gonna just
randomly poke at your software they have
a goal in mind this might be your user
data financial information you have or
goal could be something outside your
organization perhaps they want to take
advantage of an open-source librarian
you maintain that other people use
whatever the goal they won't be able to
get straight at it because it's
important to you it's probably pretty
well protected so an attacker is gonna
look for intermediate resources as
stepping-stones
they're going to investigate your
environment and try to find different
pieces that can take advantage of to
make it further into your infrastructure
these intermediate resources could be
servers running in a cluster libraries
you depend on or even your developers
themselves as your attackers investigate
they're going to try to learn about any
defensive measures you have in place
password policies auditing practices
firewall rules and the link they're
probably going to start in the process
i'muh numerating all these things from
information they can find online and
they might find a way to use all that to
wiggle around your defensive measures to
get access to information or plant
malware or other nefarious things this
series of steps leading to a successful
attack is called the kill chain and it's
our job to stop it
our first impulse after figuring out a
kill chain is I want to take one of our
defensive measures and just beef it up
add more firewall rules segment the
network instead focus on reducing the
attack surface of the pieces you use
that means removing unnecessary
components and simplifying services and
API is to reduce an attackers possible
entry points and rather than having one
strong measure in place it's more
effective to employ defense-in-depth use
a greater number of defensive measures
that overlap that way if one thing fails
for whatever reason you have another
backup behind it to protect you the big
idea build up your defenses in layers so
that the attacker has to cry as they
peel the onion now that you've seen the
defensive strategy be sure to subscribe
below to see how you can use it to
protect your supply chain automatically
discover vulnerabilities and minimize
phishing thanks for watching and for
letting me rock this excellent hat
[Music]